these reports claim to show the atomic
bombing of hiroshima japan
the world's first atomic bomb
but none of these are the bomb they
called little boy
a dw investigation has revealed that the
wrong footage has been used for decades
by media companies around the world even
our own
to portray this historic moment
let's go back to that mission in 1945.
the official camera operator bernard
waldman recorded the explosion
but his film wasn't developed properly
and was lost
another scientist however harold agnew
who observed both the hiroshima and
nagasaki missions aboard an escort plane
had brought his personal camera with him
the hoover institution in california
where his 16 millimeter film reel is
held
believes his are the only film
recordings of both mushroom clouds
[Music]
agnew's footage of hiroshima is rarely
used in tv reports and documentaries
[Music]
his shots of the second bomb dropped on
nagasaki are often used instead
[Music]
the earliest misuse dw was able to find
a short film produced by
the u.s government the associated press
gives the date of publication
as 1945.
[Music]
just 50 seconds later 15 miles from
ground zero
the enola gay is rocked by the blast
[Music]
the nagasaki bomb was immensely more
powerful than the hiroshima weapon
nagasaki weapon being a plutonium bomb
and
it had far more destructive power the
the
the mushroom cloud is is
more substantial is is bigger
you can tell from comparing the the the
two
the two bombs and the photography is
more
persuasive more convincing
this other explosion has been used to
depict hiroshima
at least since 1964 when it appeared in
a pate news film
the first atomic bomb hit an enemy
target
but it's neither hiroshima nor nagasaki
a search of atomic history archives
revealed that this massive blast
is almost certainly the cherokee
hydrogen bomb test over bikini atoll
over a decade after the end of world war
ii
errors in early productions were saved
in major archives including the
associated press
and the u.s national archives this
footage continues to be distributed to
media companies around the world
the errors may have been the result of a
simple oversight
but if so they occurred at a time when
the narrative about the u.s
war effort was tightly controlled by the
government
certainly the us has been very
determined to show off the
immense power of the weapon to
demonstrate
its its power to force supposedly the
japanese to surrender i can't really
speculate about whether they were
they were deliberately uh concocting a
uh
a misrepresentation but if i was told
that was the case it certainly wouldn't
surprise me
for 75 years the cities of hiroshima and
nagasaki
have fought to preserve the record of
the bomb's devastation
when dw contacted the hiroshima peace
memorial museum
they told us we sincerely hope that
every interested party could join us
in conveying the destruction in an
accurate way
you